Joe is next jozin Idaho hi Joe welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show
hey Dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up yeah I had a quick question
for you I know you'd rather a house be
paid for with cash but you don't yell at
people for taking out 15-year mortgage
why do you recommend putting 15% of your
income towards retirement or attacking
paying down the house extra wouldn't
that essentially be like taking over
reverse mortgage that pays you 15% of
your income invest in the market to get
a better return while at the same time
you're trying to pay down a reverse
mortgage with any extra money you have
because you're discussing a theory that
operates only in a vacuum and for 30
years I've been out here in the real
world and I've met people with no
mortgage and no money and it's not
pretty broke people with a paid-for
house and so know you need and the power
of compound interest we want to get
started putting 15% of your household
income it's not a 15% rate of return
it's 15% of your household income going
into retirement so that you get a good
steady start then above that you get
your mortgage paid off now here's what
we found we studied 10,000 actual real
millionaires not theoretical not not not
conceptual not mathematics done in a
vacuum but actual humans that were
millionaires 93% of them were not
millionaires because of an inheritance
that's an important fact in other words
they did it themselves okay then you
have to ask yourself what did they do
the average one of them paid off their
home in ten point two years and the
average one of them steadily invested in
their retirement plans 401ks Roth IRAs
and such in good growth stock mutual
funds and so what we're going with is
the data points from actual research of
what real human beings have done not
what might work mathematically if you
did it all perfect and click your heels
together
I tend my
intends to work like yours Joe I I tend
to think through the math part first and
early in my career that led me to a lot
of errors because it left out the human
behavior portion of the equation and it
left out risk if you don't count risk in
your mortgages then and you say well I'm
gonna make more on my investing than I
would on my mortgage then I'll pay out
on my mortgage but that's not true after
you're just for risk and when you leave
out risk on that because one hundred
percent the foreclosures occur on the
home of the mortgage there's risk
involved with mortgages and so when you
don't have a mortgage your risk level
goes to approximately zero well if firms
a foreclosure it goes to zero and so you
you know you have to just for all of
those things and that's what these
millionaires have done they've done it
with this combination of art and science
not just science has done it with a
combination of the understanding the
human behavior element and the
mathematics not just human behavior and
not just mathematics and that's what's
led them to become debt-free on their
homes and everything and steadily invest
through the process and truthfully I was
honestly very relieved when the study
that we did revealed that the baby steps
the way we teach them is the most
effective way to become a millionaire
and the data points are there the
largest study of millionaires ever done
in North America so that's why hey it's
a good question and a good discussion
though thank you for asking it